this video is sponsored by movie these
are bong Joon hos complete storyboards
for parasite they're meticulous and with
few exceptions the film is a pretty
direct translation of them
[Music]
chronica tie intestine by mmm
Cosmo Chapo swallows you hi little girl
career personal cook hotel in Detroit
Anna Kotori token channel at all
I guess you hope you'll enjoy yeah
Anthony one of the clear things we can
see
comparing the storyboards to the film is
that most of the differences are places
where bong ended up going with something
simpler than his storyboards you can see
this in the example I used earlier where
the storyboard indicates the peach be
put into a bag while the camera tracks
down in the film this is simplified by
removing the camera pan one reason bong
might have made this change is if the
action of blowing on the peach was
discovered in performance by actress
park sodam on set and simplifying the
shot better showcased that piece of
performance here's another example of
how bong simplifies things on set in
this scene bong eliminates some dialogue
an entire shot and simplifies these two
shots into a single shot but while he'll
make small changes simplify things or
eliminate shots you almost never add
something that isn't in the storyboard
if he does add or change something it's
usually fairly small details like moving
the arrow the housekeeper grabs from the
wall to above the door or adding a
fairly simple stationary shot like this
one bong is giving the actors room to
shift some things in their performance
but he's obviously not doing a lot of
improvisational work on set in terms of
coming up with camera movements or
character blocking coming up with
something complicated on the spot is a
lot harder than simplifying a complex
plan so don't be afraid to make your
scenes as complex as you want in the
storyboards you can always simplify on
set
[Music]
while the camera movements and scenes
your storyboarding might be complex the
storyboards themselves don't need to be
focus on conveying the key elements of
the scene as simply as possible
character and camera movements are the
first priority but you can also convey a
key element of performance fairly simply
some lines or a head turn can indicate
surprise or amazement some things might
be too tricky to draw and that's okay if
you need to you can use a label smaller
details like lighting and subtle
emotions you can leave out and sometimes
the environment around the characters
isn't important to the shot especially
if this has been previously established
in the storyboards just make sure you
have the core elements of the shot laid
out in a clearer way the most important
things being the actors position
relative to the camera their movement
and the movement of the camera but even
though you don't need to include
everything in your storyboards and
keeping them simple as good no detail is
too subtle to be included if it's
important this shot has an extremely
subtle camera move subtle enough that
even though I've watched this film
countless times and scrutinized the
cinematography and editing of this scene
for other videos I never noticed the
movement until I saw it noted in the
storyboards so however subtle a detail
if it's important to you you can include
it in the storyboards
[Music]
in parasite bunks camera is almost
always moving this movement and how it
should be done is all laid out in the
storyboards don't you stop at drawing an
arrow that shows the camera moves give
detail about how that zoom is going to
be done as the camera doing the zooming
is it a dolly push or is it a digital
zoom in post the crew should be able to
know what camera equipment they'll need
to pull off the shot just by looking at
the storyboards if the movement is too
difficult to represent just with the
frames you can add some diagrams to help
the crew better understand how you want
to move the camera bong does this
especially with the more complex scenes
involving a lot of people and it's not
just for camera movement for the chaotic
finale he includes a diagram just to
show the position of everything and
where the characters will be moving
[Music]
don't be afraid to whip out your phone
camera if you're planning a shoot in
real locations and you know what they
are already you might as well integrate
them into the storyboards for the
mansion which bong designed as a set he
occasionally used 3d renderings to show
what the house would look like once it
was built
[Music]
if you have stunts or action you have to
storyboard in a way that's actually
possible for example if you need to swap
between stunt performers and actors you
need to plan a cut into the storyboard
to cover up that swap as you draw your
storyboards you're essentially pre
editing the film so you have to think
about the things that would usually be
taken care of by editing it's possible
to storyboard things that would be
impossible to shoot so make sure you're
thinking ahead to production and
post-production it's also important to
think about the transition between shots
and scenes and how you can use that
juxtaposition for your story and edit
like this one that contrasts the poor
family and the dark and getting wet
against the rich family high and dry and
in the Sun or this that contrasts the
rich family's closet against the poor
family trying to find clothes are
specifically planned out in the
storyboard don't forget to draw little
devil horns on your characters if
they're being bad storyboards are a
powerful tool but in the books
introduction bong says he doesn't think
storyboarding is necessary for making
good films bong worries that being so
structured eliminates some of the magic
that comes from spontaneity onset and
this might be the case but he says that
his main motivation for storyboarding is
to alleviate his anxiety if oscar-winner
bong joon-ho is anxious about the work
he does the new and I can take comfort
in the fact that having anxiety about
our work doesn't mean we lack the skill
and if we're willing like bong we can
find methods that help us overcome that
anxiety of meticulously planning things
out and then translating those plans
straight to film is what works for you
then go ahead storyboard like bong
joon-ho
[Music]
ruby is an online streaming cinema
filled with high-quality films that they
hand curate their curation is one of the
things that makes movie not just a place
you go to because you're looking for
something you know you already want to
watch but a place that you go to to find
new and interesting things to watch the
film I want to recommend to you today is
the 2013 polish film Ida
it's an emotional drama with some
incredible black-and-white
cinematography and if you haven't seen
it yet you can check it out when you go
to movie.com slash thomas flight to
start your extended 30-day free trial
that's movie comm slash thomas flight
thanks so much for watching special
thank you to my patrons go to
patreon.com/scishow slate to learn more
about how you can get bonus content and
support my channel at the same time